of love and sympathy and support for the
people of Christchurch and particularly
for the communities that have been on
the receiving end of this attack our
hearts go out to all the victims their
families and of course everyone else who
has been affected and at the same time
we acknowledge the extraordinary bravery
and courage of our police our first
responders and all those that are now
supporting the victims of this attack
today our focus is very much on
providing practical support to the
families there is a lot for them to be
going through and our hearts with them
but our practical support needs to turn
to them as well and then there is the
wider community of Christchurch we've
all been affected everyone has been
touched in some way shape or form and
the messages that I've had overnight
have been a desire to come together as a
community and to reach out and offer
solidarity to our community a Muslim
community a part of our community we are
a very diverse City and Christchurch we
have welcomed new people into our city
we are talking about people in the city
who have lived here for years and years
and years they are our friends they are
our neighbors we embrace them at this
time and I know that I speak for all of
the people in Christchurch when I say
how much we want to come together to
support them so we want to work together
with those communities to ensure that we
do this appropriately and in support and
give them the time and the space that
they need to deal with the immediate
issues at hand we still have injured
people in the hospital so we will find a
time and a place for us to come together
and to share that sense of grief and
loss but also to share that sense of
love compassion and support that we feel
for these communities the next thing is
that people have said that they want to
lay floral tributes or other tributes
and memory and in respect of those who
have died and so we have made available
the Botanic Garden wall along Rolleston
Ave offer such the center the reason we
chose that place is because it's close
to the hospital very close to the
hospital and so there is a direct
connection with the people whose lives
have been lost and we know that the
police still have Corden's on the two
mosques and we do want to ask people to
stay away from those places we will
ensure that those tributes are made
available to the community at an
appropriate time the next thing that has
come through as a strong desire also to
contribute money there are people who
offering financial support that want to
help out I know that victim supports
have set up an immediate helpline fund
for supporting the family members the
victims of this terrible attack and the
Christchurch foundation which has been
recently established will also set up a
fund because it won't just be for the
immediate aftermath of what we have
experienced in the city but it will be
about rebuilding communities rebuilding
what has been lost and ensuring that the
communities are able to be well
supported and to the future and that
will be announced by the Christchurch
foundation this morning and all of the
flags are flying at half-mast on our
council own buildings today and until
further notice this is an expression of
civic support for the communities and
that have been experienced and many
events at the weekend have been canceled
as well some of them will be known to
you already the cricket test at the
Hagley oval between New Zealand and
Bangladesh which I think is a powerful
statement of the support from both sides
of you know the the sporting fraternity
that were gathered here in the city for
an important game - out of respect not
play that game today the Bryan Adams
concert will not proceed either and all
sport at Hagley Park as canceled until
further notice thank you well sadly
because of the numbers of people who
have been killed there will have to be a
large number of funerals there are very
specific requirements in terms of Muslim
funerals and the council was working
very closely with the communities to
ensure that there are proper places
available for preparation and for
appropriate our graves to be dug they
are being dug today sorry
I'm very shocked that it has happened
here but I'm shocked that it's happened
in New Zealand if this had happened in
any other city in this country I would
be equally shocked and I think the
reason that we have been targeted and
this was as I understand it a deliberate
decision to target our city and our
country was because we are a safe city
in a safe country and that was the
message so in my response to the choice
of Christchurch
by this terrorist individual who chooses
to terrorize our city it is an act of
cowardice that he has performed it is
something that will I guess there are no
words to describe the revulsion that I
feel for the propaganda that he wanted
to bring with us and I will not give
voice to that propaganda his was the
voice of hate and the only way that
communities can respond to the voice of
hate is to come together and love
compassion and kindness
I haven't been so concerned at all I've
obviously only been the mayor of
Christchurch for the last five and a
half years and prior to that though I
was a member of parliament for over 20
years and the sort of extremism is not
something that we've seen here but he is
not from here he came here he came here
with hate honest heart and intention to
kill in his mind so he did not develop
his hatred here he came here to perform
this act of terrorism no I haven't
spoken to the mayor of Dunedin I've
heard this morning that on the radio
that there is an interest and a property
in Dunedin I've spoken to the Prime
Minister I've spoken to the minister of
police I've spoken to the minister of
civil defense so I certainly have
reached out I've received messages from
almost every mayor in the city and
actually a number of mirrors from around
the world have contacted me as well to
share their sense of horror and
compassion for our city
I heard the Commissioner of Police
correct that statement last night that
was there were two devices and one car
as well he said